[Music]
did any of you guys see that airline
flight where the um all the christians
on the plane i already knew i already
knew dude where they were singing the
song yeah there was a flight where uh
these like christian uh ministry group
they got up in the aisle and they
started singing a prey song that is some
christians
and the whole plane had to sit there and
just like listen to it oh they weren't
singing along do you guys think that's
rude some of them yeah you think that's
rude for that that's what the divisive
thing is here i'll show unless the
song's fired i don't think it was like
fire per se but it was
man [ __ ] that dude i want a gypsy with
an accordion
that's the dope voice not my first
choice of music hey watch out man this
guy's singaporean but
what's he would you ride
oh man i take it all back when you ride
the trains or buses in [ __ ] europe
right there'll be a gypsy dude that just
pops out of nowhere and he'll he'll just
start playing the accordion and i'm just
like man that's [ __ ] tight that's
talent i like that but the jams are good
though right jabs are sick dude and i
just want to just [ __ ] toss all kinds
of money there that that kind of reminds
me of the you know the dave chappelle's
kit
where the white guy brings out the
guitar and then they're like shut the
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
starts playing the beat they're like
my first thought was
my first thought was if that was a
gospel group i think everything yeah
yeah that's true yeah it was like a
legit gospel group everybody
like shut the [ __ ] up dude it's like
they seen the brady bunch where they go
to hawaii and they start playing they're
like shut the [ __ ] down like oh sorry
and then come back down the brady bunch
movie yeah yeah that's a good movie
dude yeah it was gospel i don't think
anybody else probably got it
was it some singaporean kid or something
it was a singaporean the guy that's got
the guitar yeah he's the same wait so
did he pull the guitar like he was on
the plane right that's his carry-on yeah
yeah so he's sitting down like
it's about that time
what's the elevation we're at 30 000
okay let's go like you're just trying to
go to sleep it's based on elevation
you're just like what the [ __ ] is going
on the captain made a [ __ ] like
announcement because they're so closer
to god in the heavens so they're just
like
it's time guys
let's do it like they got with their
prayer group and they're like you'll be
crazy and we go up and start [ __ ]
praising the lord in heaven and then on
the christian sites they were saying
um so the ministry group not only were
they just returning on a flight from
ukraine after a month of like a
missionary service and like supply like
they did good [ __ ] okay so they there's
that there's that right there so it was
a flight from ukraine yeah like it might
have been connecting or something but it
it they're basically returning from
like serving the uh people on the border
guitar so that's already like if you
knew that on the plane you're already
gonna kind of be cool with them yeah uh
they also checked with the staff the
staff said we'll check with the captain
the captain said that would be great so
this was all like they actually asked
for permission cool it looked like most
people weren't joined yeah i think the
mo the main people that didn't enjoy are
just people watching the clip yeah
i'm clowning it but i wouldn't care i
mean i wouldn't mind music on the plane
it was actually i like the context it's
a lot more bearable
right with with that context especially
praise music is hilarious yeah we grew
up on that [ __ ] dude it's kind of it's
funny yeah
it is funny and they only did that one
song it was three to four minutes long
and then they were just like yeah
i wanna imagine they did a whole
performance the funny thing is the guy
the guy who posted it he's actually from
that ministry group and the caption that
he posted on his uh video is we are
taking this flight over for jesus
[Laughter]
oh why do you say it like sounds so
terroristic
oh my god yeah dude and everyone's like
i'm okay with it christian terrorism
i want to get a bunch of buddhist
buddies together and we're going to have
a [ __ ] live chat bro let's go let's
have a meditation session you know but
did you guys see what um ilhan omar says
yes yeah yeah so uh
she's a us rep for minnesota's fifth
congressional district she's muslim and
she tweeted the clip and said uh like
imagine if we were trying to have a
prayer session with the reaction be dude
i love ilan
maybe i mean i don't know if they have
this in muslim churches or whatever but
do they bust out like a [ __ ] electric
guitar and start singing muslim songs i
don't know like i don't think so muslim
christian rock i mean not like religious
rock or whatever like i don't know yeah
like they got they got muslim hymns yeah
if they bust out a [ __ ] acoustic
maybe it's a sitar i don't know they
[ __ ] started
banging it out and start i would have
been like dude music is dope like no
matter what it is especially if they get
approved by the captain yeah yeah i want
to see a [ __ ] indian dude bust out a
pipe and [ __ ] and his cobra pops out and
they start doing that [ __ ]
you know on the subways
there's people that like dance on the
subway like you know there's like
railings oh dude yeah there's like feet
people yeah like people like this this
group called showtime yeah i know you
can just pull up to the to the subway
like in your train it happens anywhere
like it's happened to me like five times
like
they'll just get on and start like
flying like rey mysterio on the [ __ ]
subway
and they never hit anyone and it's like
eight o'clock in the morning wow and
what do they do like they dance for tips
and they just dance for tips yeah yeah
it's just sometimes the music's so
[ __ ] loud
why do they do that all the time they
gotta they have it on full blast yeah
and it's like eight o'clock people
trying to go to work but i gotta get
people hyped
a lot of people don't like it because
it's so early in the morning but they do
get tips though because you know it's
like the first time you see it it's like
this is the sickest thing i've ever seen
in my life yeah it's actually the fourth
time you're like
yeah if it's in your regular commute
yeah yeah
like oh yeah
and they're like god damn it
ladies and gentlemen we are show time
like
what's everyone's general reaction on
the planet i mean on the subway people
that have seen it don't even look at it
anymore but it's always tourists that
are just like
[ __ ] this is so cool this is the big
city bro the big apple i wish there was
a airplane version of that
they're dancing on the plane yeah doing
worms down the island
yeah
like all right you know what i think
they need to bring that on the airplane
imagine going through the usa
just so you could [ __ ] dance brother
they're like all right i'm gonna do this
[ __ ]
you're again you're buying tickets for
that reason
guys the overheads a lot so please tip
generously
[Laughter]
[Applause]
or what if there was like a stand-up
comedian that would do that
and he's like he's like he does his
material on the flight you can't [ __ ] um
he stands up ladies and gentlemen
my name is dave japan it's all airplane
comedy yeah
only airplane food only talked about
in sky mall yeah or the guy with the
buckets he just brings all his budget
he's like oh my carry-on you guys know
that [ __ ] trump guy he just he stacks
all these buckets they have like one of
those guys in everything
oh
imagine going to the plane you see that
guy on the line you're just like
[ __ ] no no he's he's boarding me what
are you what the [ __ ] do you want yeah
they're like
the tsa guys looking at it like through
the [ __ ] scanner what is that buckets
okay cool
you're sitting next to him he's like hey
show time's in 30 minutes
you can't wait to [ __ ] do it
[Laughter]
that'll be sick if we get street
performers on airplanes
i mean it is true though because like
like any anything like that one time is
probably pretty cool yeah or like ironic
or funny but like if that's in your
regular day-to-day [ __ ] [ __ ] dude dude i
kind of want to do that just on the
plane the guy that walks on the glass
and [ __ ] goes down the aisles the silver
guy silver guy
in the aisle like
well he would have to get ready on the
plane right yeah he goes
like spray paint why is the whole
bathroom silver now
it's like during turbulence
oh my gosh
it's just like standing in the morning
you've seen
they had so many street shows in hawaii
too yeah right like yeah on the strip
yeah like there's everybody there
and they have pretty much one of
everything too like that they would have
here or anywhere else i wonder who
decides like which bum
sees like the bucket drummer guy and
goes i can do that in my hometown or
whatever like well they they definitely
do you have to get permits and you can't
have like the same people do the same
thing
oh really yeah you have to buy you have
to buy a spot oh that's yeah so that way
it's not [ __ ] 18 silver guys
hey that might be cool though you're
walking it's just frozen people the
whole time
it's a silver street yeah they're just
welcome
like you can be the most still by the
hollywood uh like on venice and [ __ ]
like venice is i don't think venice is
permitted they just all [ __ ] run
their own shows but third street
promenade bumblebee out there yeah he's
he's permanent i don't know about the
people that just walk through it
but if you're situated you you do have
to get a a permit to do it yeah third
street problem you also want to
diversify the entertainment that is
there because they're not going to be
like [ __ ] everyone's a b-boy you know
those guys that do like they'll they'll
get like five people in a row and
they'll backflip over them yeah yeah
they gotta do that [ __ ] that's that
venice in the air baby that's what
they're gonna do
they gotta do that [ __ ] in first class
that's what it is
joe i wanna see them fail a couple times
joe's jumps hit the front guy yeah crash
that one's gonna get sued by the whole
first class yeah yeah everyone has a
lawyer right there two two of the the
two captains are also there too
who's flying this [ __ ]
this is great they're kneeling down
ready for the backflip
just idea there's football
dance crews hey maybe mike mike tyson's
was just an exhibition fight
[Laughter]
[Music]
it was a false flag yeah it was all set
up it's a false flag event bro they're
trying to like start a war man i haven't
seen a good street performance in a
minute because of covey dude we got to
go to venice or some [ __ ]
the sky performing just think about it
you guys i mean what if they could just
have somebody present the skymall items
and try to sell you
you'll be like you need this zombie
statue coming out of the ground trust me
is that what they sell
like
it's like when you go to a 3d movie you
need those glasses like trust me you'll
need this i just thought skye mall was
like the sharper image it is but it's
like on crack it's like the weirdest
[ __ ] it's like whatever they have
surplus of at the phone they got chia
pets on there they do yeah they got not
only do they still have them on the
thing i think they do for sure they have
the thing where it's like you you put
the coin in and it'll go in the circle
down to what size it's supposed to fit
oh i love those order or nickel and
they'll go
quarter goes here
yeah when you [ __ ] have a you have to
make your roll of pennies and quarters
and [ __ ] before you take it to the yeah
[ __ ] like that [ __ ] yeah it's a useless
thing i read that
parts with a highlighter he's like oh
this is good he cuts it out
that would make sense to do that and it
would be the same guy that tries to sell
you shoe cleaner
[Music]
you